- Hey, have you seen Patrick around?
- Which one is Patrick again?
- He's the one, he's got
like a big head, just big.
- Oh yeah, he's in the back.
He's trying to get a hat on his head.
It's not going really well.
- His head is big, isn't it?
- [Voiceover] These are
problems that only people
with big heads will understand.
There's a few different
types of big heads.
There's people with round big heads.
There's people with
optical illusion big heads,
where up front, it looks normal
but then they turn to
the side and oh my God.
Who saw that coming?
You realize that things were only made
for people with normal-sized
heads, like helmets.
(grunts)
- Ooh here, try these on.
- [Voiceover] And sunglasses.
Hats are the devil.
Anyone with a big head can tell you
that wearing a hat makes you feel
like you're wearing a yarmulke.
Fitted hats are terrible.
Snap-backs are by far, the worst.
Having one snap is the most embarrassing
thing about wearing this hat.
All the other kids look great,
but your mom had to attach
extra holes so it would fit.
And it wasn't even the matching color.
And people with normal
sized heads don't get it.
- Try this on.
- No, no, no.
- Come on, try this on.
- I don't look good in hats.
- The color is great, come on.
- No, I don't wanna wear a hat!
"Oh, ha ha, Pat's got a big 'ol head.
"Put him in a hat."
Not funny, it's not funny!
Sorry, I'm sorry.
- [Voiceover] The one thing that does make
people with big heads feel better
is the fact that famous
people have big heads.
Like Jay Leno.
Alec Baldwin.
Idris Elba.
Angelina Jolie.
Tyra Banks.
Rihanna.
And Nicholas Cage.
So the fact that those
people went through this
means that there's hope for all of us.
Hang in there, big head.
(whimsical music)
(grunts)